pour tout regarder à 17 ans on lui en a
fait part avant justement son aval avant
mais finalement ces images enfants mais
les images mais il les cherche pas non
mais faut les chercher
comme ça
tu es très étriqué et en fait le
dialogue n'est pas possible parce que tu
coupes la parole moi
s'il te plaît dans le respect c'est que
là quand elle dit nous on est exposé nos
enfants est-ce que tu connais les
enfants de Valérie est-ce que tu connais
les écoles
[Musique]
dans l'école
ils peuvent le savoir
Amandine Amandine Gilles on sait qui est
ta fille dans l'école on sait que jamais
et c'est votre haine que vous répondez
toujours la maman quand même
qui sodomise une maman qui a fait ça
montre le moi
vous avez le droit de le faire
à 20h à 20h30
il va générer justement encore une fois
tout un montage en époque sur les
réseaux sociaux
tu es pas bienveillante donc je n'ai pas
envie de parler non non mais moi je suis
bien moi j'ai fait mon yoga je suis zen
tu ne l'es pas ce qu'il faut faire la
part des choses tu as le droit de pas
être d'accord mais par contre tu nous
manques de respect tout le temps et stop
moi je te dis stop je n'ai pas envie
d'échanger avec toi Amanda
c'est Cyril
finissez après non je répondrai pas hein
c'est pas une question de respect parce
qu'elle est toujours dans l'attaque en
fait dans le dénigrement c'est pas
possible vous dites juste pourquoi je
trouve ça choquant pour vos enfants et
vous vous
posons pas assez encore une fois
un bar je vous dis juste que tous les
enfants ont accès au porno on ne va pas
les nôtres alors éduquer vos enfants
alors
est-ce que moi je l'ai réveillé
il est en train de regarder
n'importe quoi
largement parlé moi je comprends pas
trop votre discours par rapport au voilà
c'est notre kiffe et on a envie de faire
ça pourquoi aller faire ça sur les
réseaux et pourquoi les chiens mais par
rapport au métier de harder quitte à
faire un choix pourquoi vous faites pas
plus que ça et pas et laissez tomber les
vidéos à trois balles à deux balles de
la cheville justement c'est le site
c'est le site professionnel
dit en magnétisant nos contenus mais
c'est pas un secret mais en fait on fait
ce qu'on aime et évidemment qu'elle ne
devient avec on va pas mais on va pas
cracher dans la soupe arrêtons des
hypocrites